The very best horror movies give viewers scenes
that linger and fester in the mind like vengeful
spirits, even after decades have passed. The
images are burned into our collective memories.
Here are the scariest horror movie
scenes for every year since 1990.
In 1990, the psychological landscape of
the United States was complicated. The
paranoia and fragmentation of the titular
character in Jacob's Ladder would have been
somewhat familiar to mentally and emotionally
fatigued Americans at the end of the Cold War.
But the singular horror of Jacob's Ladder extends
beyond an era-specific appeal. While exploring
themes from PTSD to the biblical, the film employs
a unique brand of body horror through special
effects that were amazingly all done in camera,
with none digitally added in post-production.
And that makes this hospital scene in
Jacob's Ladder all the more freaky,
because as Jacob is bound to a gurney and wheeled
past people scrambling with supernatural fervor
over the vents above him or rocking frantically
back and forth in straitjackets, through bloody
curtains and past severed limbs, you know
all that horror was in some way very real.
The scene in The Silence of the Lambs in which
serial killer Buffalo Bill stalks FBI agent
Clarice Starling with night vision goggles
is a reminder of why the horror genre has
long made use of first-person perspective,
most notably in found footage-style pieces,
to introduce a more panicked element that hits
much closer to home. The scene makes us feel
like we have to look over our shoulders
for a threat lurking just out of frame.
In this scene, the perspective offered to us
is the first-person point of view of a
serial killer stalking our protagonist,
which makes us feel just as helpless and
at the mercy of his evil whims as Clarice.
Rather than pick up where the series left off,
Twin Peaks: Fire Walk With Me was set up as a
prequel to David Lynch's iconic TV mystery Twin
Peaks, and didn't exactly tie up the series' loose
ends. Possibly because he was able to show much
more of a dark side to society than on network TV,
the most terrible things that happen in
Fire Walk With Me are the emotional traumas
suffered by Laura Palmer. And we all know
this tragic story only leads to her death.
While it may have been unconventional,
Lynch's direction in this prequel
reached even deeper levels of
horror than it might have otherwise.
Which is why Laura Palmer's dream was
easily the scariest movie scene in 1992.
"Don't take the ring, Laura."
There's one Stephen King film adaptation that
literally has everything you could ever want,
and it's 1993's Needful Things. Leland Gaunt, a
disguised demon, arrives in a small Maine town
and opens an antique shop that
offers items too good to be true.
All he asks in return is that you
pull pranks on your neighbors.
What's subtly disturbing about Needful Things
is that, although it's clear something is amiss,
Gaunt's meddling simply seems mischievous, even
harmless for a while, rather than outright evil.
Arguably, it is the townspeople's own grudges,
prejudices, and pathologies that cause these
conflicts to escalate, and ultimately,
multiple people to lose their lives.
That psychological underpinning
really sells the unconventional,
chilling horror of two women fighting
to the death in a farmhouse kitchen.
Can the seventh installment of a
horror franchise ever really deliver?
Wes Craven's New Nightmare managed to, with
one scene in particular. Part of what makes
Heather's nightmare in the hospital so scary is
simple. Hospitals are supposed to be safe spaces,
and she has finally fallen asleep. It's
also scary because it begins with Freddy's
voice coming out of a child's mouth
as he stares coldly into her face.
A doctor arrives, but Heather's hysteria increases
as she sees Freddy's hands protruding from the
doctor's coat, then looks up again to see that
Freddy has somehow infiltrated the hospital staff.
The rapid escalation makes this
a genuinely scary sequence,
even more so because it appears
afterward to be all in her mind.
In 1995, we were blessed with the sixth
entry in the Halloween franchise. Halloween:
The Curse of Michael Myers managed to
give us a pretty solid scare when Tommy,
played perfectly by Paul
Rudd, first meets Michael.
As Tommy struggles to free Kara from a locked
room, Michael appears at the other end of the
hallway. Tommy's response is one of bemusement
and disbelief, then fear, as he frantically
tries to break the doorknob in time with an
unwieldy fire extinguisher, which makes all
of his movements seem even more futile and frantic
and adds a little more scare value to the scene.
Scream's satirical approach to the horror
genre has helped it endure as a classic.
In fact, Scream's scariest moment lulled us
into a false sense of security and trust.
Billy couldn't be the killer; he'd just been
attacked! The impact of the twist was heightened
by the disconcerting sight of Billy nonchalantly
licking his own blood off his fingers,
revealing that it's just corn syrup, just
like they used for pig's blood in Carrie.
Couple that with Stu's sadistic grin,
the explanation that the two have had a
vendetta against Sid and her family and
murdered her mother, and the fact that
Billy and Sid just slept together, and
it's enough to make your stomach turn.
David Lynch makes the list again with
Lost Highway and its "mystery man,"
who approaches protagonist Fred at a party
and claims to have met him at his own home.
What follows is one of the most bizarre
sequences of 1997, made even creepier by
the earnest but empty smile of the "mystery man,"
his lilting voice, and his peculiarly pale makeup.
He insists he is at Fred's house at that moment,
even as he is standing right in front of him.
The fact that the "mystery man" is able
to appear simultaneously so amicable
and threatening is unreal, and Robert
Blake's performance will haunt audiences
as surely as the confusing
nightmare it foreshadows.
Even if you haven't seen this version of the
film, you'll recognize this scene from 1998's
Ringu if you've seen the 2002 American remake.
The specter clambering out of the television
screen in this shot might be familiar to you as
Samara, but in the original movie her name was
Sadako. And rather than seeing her
whole face as you do in The Ring,
in Ringu we only see her bulging eye,
which is arguably even more threatening
and definitely helps lift this scene to the
number one slot for scary moments of 1998.
Before found footage became an overused
trope, The Blair Witch Project made it
famous. The young filmmakers behind the project
did things in a completely new and effective way.
They ended up shooting about 20 hours of footage,
for a film with minimal scripted dialogue.
Editing trimmed their 20 hours of footage down to
the sub-90-minute run time you can watch today,
and one of the sequences that made the cut
ended up earning its place among the most iconic
scenes in horror. Through a handheld camera, the
run-down house in the woods becomes a labyrinth,
and by the time the scene concludes, you'll feel
you've aged years, not just an hour and a half.
"Where are you going?"
"I've got to return some videotapes."
We don't need to muse on the unlikeliness of
this scene, thanks to the comically absurd
precedent set by American Psycho from
the opening scenes of the 2000 film.
Instead, we can just enjoy it in all its
gory glory. It starts when Patrick Bateman,
played by Christian Bale, kills Elizabeth
in some extremely bloody manner.
Christie, who had joined them for the encounter,
had climbed out of bed earlier and begins to run.
On the way out, she sees the bodies of several
other women before finally escaping to the stairs,
which loop downward for many floors. Conveniently,
Bateman has a chainsaw, which he drops down the
center of the stairwell, and it somehow lands on
and kills Christie in yet another bloody mess.
It's hard to raise a kid. It's even harder
when you look down at her and she has the
wrinkled hand of an old woman, half-obscured
under a veil, who just keeps on insisting,
no matter how frantically you assert
otherwise, "I am your daughter."
This scene from 2001's The Others
scores extra creepy points because
there's nothing really sinister
about the old woman under the veil
except that she's, well, old. She
doesn't even have a creepy voice.
The real danger in this scene appears to be
Nicole Kidman's character, who violently shakes
her daughter and tears at her veil to banish the
apparition, only to have it transform back into
her confused, hurt daughter when witnesses arrive,
making the mother look like the real monster.
"You're wicked, wicked wicked!"
If there's one scene that teaches us never to
underestimate the simple elements of horror,
like the sudden appearance of a zombie, it's
the scene in the chapel from 28 Days Later.
Stumbling upon an abandoned church littered
with the dead bodies of the congregation
is honestly pretty scary already, and you'd
think that a response to Jim's hopeful,
"Hello?" would have been just the relief he
needed. When that response comes, though, it's
from a zombie lurching towards him. He doesn't
immediately run. That changes quickly, though.
Another zombie pops up, and soon, the whole horde
awakens. Jim's naivete, sticking around rather
than running at the first sight of the undead,
gave us one of our scariest zombie moments.
The scariest scene in the remake
of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre,
and the year 2003, didn't
involve a single chainsaw.
Instead, this foreboding scene is made extra
scary due to its pacing and sound design.
A group of pigs trundling
through the living room is weird,
but not especially dangerous. A porcelain head
and sewing machine on a desk is definitely creepy.
Kemper sees an eerie old photograph before
hearing a sound from another room and continuing
his search for Erin. The backdrop of dismayed
black-and-white cartoon faces playing on the TV
as he is abruptly killed with a sledgehammer
is the perfect introduction to Leatherface.
The sadistic game-master has taken various
forms in all manner of horror films,
but none of them quite gets under the skin
like the one in Saw who set the original
"reverse bear trap." This "game" is so
titled because the victim, Amanda, has a
device strapped to her head that will, when the
timer goes off, rip her mouth open permanently.
As if that weren't bad enough, Amanda has to
retrieve the only key to the device from the
stomach of her cell mate, using a knife. The
creepy green light and disorienting camera work
add to the horror, but what really gets you is
the narration. Amanda is telling her own story,
so you know that she got out. But the
fact that you know how she had to do
it makes that prior knowledge
grim rather than comforting.
The 2005 Rob Zombie flick The Devil's Rejects
surprises us when a hotel housekeeper finds one
of the title trio's victims, Wendy, still
alive, hanging on the back of the door,
and wearing another victim's face.
She collapses onto the housekeeper,
screaming wordlessly from behind the makeshift
mask before both of them make a run for it.
You can honestly see the next part coming.
Wendy can't see out of someone else's eye
holes and stumbles through the desert
and onto the road to flag down a car.
A truck runs her over. But the scariest
part wasn't her death. It was finding
her alive and watching her flail toward
her doom wearing another person's face.
The fact that the 2006 remake of The Hills
Have Eyes centers around cannibal mutants in
the Southwestern desert hints that there is a good
bit of sci-fi involved to give all of the horror
an extra edge. The hills in which the
Carter family's car breaks down are
plagued by mysterious disappearances connected
to nuclear testing in an old mining town nearby.
"We absolutely had to see
the desert, didn't we Bob?"
And if the cannibalism-ghost town combo isn't
enough, the impetus for the scariest scene
is the abduction of a baby, which leads to
Doug's ultimate confrontation with the mutants,
which just might be the
scariest movie scene from 2006.
The first Paranormal Activity
film elevated the found footage
subgenre of horror cinema. Whereas
the cameras in The Blair Witch Project
were intentionally limited in scope,
completely subjective and without an
omniscient point of view, Paranormal
Activity gave us the opposite in 2007.
The cameras offered a nearly full perspective of
each room they depicted, often unnervingly so.
The setup in Paranormal Activity makes us squirm
so much because we can see "everything," but can't
move, and it's night time, and we're all alone
with the characters. This cold distance heightens
the horror on the 21st and final night, easily
making it the scariest horror movie scene of 2007.
This scene from The Strangers was shot so well
that its unnerving frame may be familiar to you
from the movie's promotional poster, for which
it was eventually used. Though the shot itself
is about as static as a still image for a few
moments, it's the chilling stillness combined
with Liv Tyler's slow, casual movements
that make it so creepy in the film itself.
It's also creepy just how long we
have to sit and watch and wait,
knowing that the intruder is standing mere
feet away and the character doesn't know it.
When will she realize that someone is lurking
and how will it happen? Some jump scares are
frightening because they come out of nowhere, but
this one reveals a piece of the scare ahead of
time, leaving us anxiously expecting another one
at any moment because we know it must be coming.
Lars Von Trier is no stranger
to being condemned for his art.
Many of his films have earned bans
and walkouts. His 2009 experimental
horror film Antichrist was even banned in
France seven years after it was released.
This film features many of the
most disturbing scenes imaginable,
but one that really sticks is the fox
disemboweling itself in the woods.
When Willem Dafoe's character stumbles
upon the fox, he finds the animal ever
so slowly pulling the flesh away from its
body until a lean strip of it just snaps off.
While the fox's subsequent announcement that...
"Chaos reigns."
...is viewed by some fans as
so ridiculous as to provide
unintentional comic relief, the moments
preceding it will chill you to the bone.
What makes this Insidious scene, in which the
red demon face briefly appears behind Josh,
played by Patrick Wilson, work so well is the
fact that it hardly does anything different
from the traditional jump scare beyond a
few key elements. We've seen faces appear
behind people's shoulders before, and we've seen
people freak out at something only they can see.
But what's compelling about this scene is that
the characters are talking about the
demonic presence at that very moment,
and then it appears, brazenly, as if daring them
to speak more. The red color is also a vibrant,
attention-grabbing contrast to the shadowy
forms demons typically take in horror films.
Most importantly, the demon
appears in broad daylight,
while characters are seated in a sunny room
around a table. This demon was just stopping
by because it could, and now the family
has to find a way to go on with their day.
Most horror movies build tension in a manner
that revolves around the source of horror itself,
like a poltergeist or serial
killer. But in 2011's You're Next,
the source of tension leading up to its scariest
moments is almost always the characters.
The family's bickering dominates just about
every scene, with the camera and the audience
scrambling to keep up. This creates a sense
of unease, not unlike scenes in which someone
is being chased or hears strange noises and
keeps turning to look over their shoulder.
"Excuse me? You say that like it's my fault."
As the details and drama unfold, we learn that
this family is so dysfunctional that a couple
of the kids have hired hitmen in creepy,
cultish animal masks to disrupt dinnertime.
Genuinely frightening from start to finish,
Sinister makes it hard to pick the scariest scene,
but you know that this film is where you'll find
2012's winner. As many delightfully disturbing
moments as there are, protagonist Ellison, played
by Ethan Hawke, stumbles upon the best one early
in the film when he's digging through old home
movies in the attic of his family's new house.
These movies depict the murders of the previous
family, filmed on a handheld camera. For one
thing, even if you can reasonably guess, you
really don't know what's coming. You're not
sure why the family made a home video of their
lawnmower at night, until you encounter the most
artful and unconventional jump scare of the
year. It's not a demon jumping out at you,
but it's a window into the fact that something
absolutely sinister happened at this house.
If "things that go bump in the night" are standard
horror fare, The Conjuring was a bit of a horror
renaissance. Early on, the film equips itself
for sound-based scares. The Perron family has a
special game they like to play called "hide and
clap," which is like a variation on Marco Polo.
"Yeah, let's play!"
In this scene, the creepy sound apparently
comes from Cindy sleepwalking and banging
her head against the door. But after
she returns to bed, the sound starts
again. While a minor misdirection, it
was effective. We thought we had ruled
out the supernatural as the source of the sound
when we discovered that Cindy was causing it,
meaning that we might have jumped when it resumed,
or at the very least went on higher alert,
inadvertently priming ourselves for the fright
of seeing the witch on top of the wardrobe.
To make fear more tangible to its audience,
one approach is to make it more intimate. Many
directors choose to accomplish this through
cinematography or editing, but It Follows
takes a decidedly unique and modern approach
by tying its horror to sexual intercourse.
For much of the film, we don't see the demonic
entity that passes from person to person after
they've done the deed, and when we do, it takes
a different form for each victim. First, it is a
woman, which only Jay, the afflicted young woman,
can see. However, the specter can take any form
it pleases and could be anyone, which would be
terrifying on its own, but its next iteration, the
Tall Man who causes Jay to leap out the window,
is the stuff of your nightmares' nightmares.
You know you've seen a great horror movie
when a glorified folk tale can reach nearly
400 years through the centuries and
still send chills down your spine,
especially when the title menace is only
glimpsed fleetingly for most of the story.
In The Witch's scariest scene, the witches
have barely revealed themselves thus far.
That doesn't stop the family from going on a
witch hunt, with only each other as targets.
Ultimately, with a little supernatural
meddling, they tear each other apart.
It's certainly creepy when the witch appears
in the shed without entering through the door,
but it's even more horrifying that the
children's parents lock them out there.
Interspersed with and exacerbating this
tragic terror are shots of Thomasin's
mother nursing what she sees as her baby,
while in reality, a crow gnaws at her chest.
Sibling rivalry can get bitter, but you'd never
expect it to literally taste sweet. Apparently,
though, if you come from a family of cannibals,
it can. Raw's Justine, formerly a lifelong
vegetarian, doesn't think about or behave
around human flesh as if it were just another
food or dietary preference. Her cravings are
pathological, primal, and uncontrollable.
It's genuinely terrifying to watch her go through
her transformation and discover that her body
can only survive on human meat. But watching her
examine her sister's accidentally severed finger,
then nibble it, then pick it clean, while
the soundtrack builds and her sister lies
unconscious in the next room, is one of the
most alarming things you'll see this year
if you didn't see Raw when it premiered in
2016. It's certainly the most alarming thing
Justine's sister saw when she woke up just
in time to see Justine finishing her snack.
One of the most horrifying thoughts is that true
horror exists not in a private, hypnosis-induced
nightmare but rather endemically in our way of
life. Filmmaker Jordan Peele explained that the
Sunken Place in Get Out was a symbol for the
marginalized and all the systems that keep
marginalized communities oppressed, specifically
in this case the impact of the prison-industrial
complex on Black communities as well
as the lack of representation in film.
It's frightening to see Chris from the outside,
paralyzed but present, versus the inside,
sunken and silenced. The Sunken Place makes
every other second of Get Out that much more
terrifying by offering the context and revealing
the nature of Logan's outburst and other clues
earlier in the film. What may seem inconsequential
or "not quite right" in film and life to those who
only see a thirty-second scene is flat-out wrong
for those whose vantage point is the Sunken Place.
If you're ever struggling to decide
between a horror movie and a dance movie,
you need look no further than
the 2018 version of Suspiria,
and after one early scene, you might
not want to look any further, period.
Not exactly a remake of the color-saturated
1977 classic, the 2018 version follows similar
themes and characters but expands greatly on the
more abstract realm of emotional provocation.
At least, that was director Luca Guadagnino's
intent, and provocative doesn't even begin to
cover the scene of poor Olga's death at
the unknowing hands and feet of Suzy,
whose dance has been somehow supernaturally
linked to Olga's helpless body. As Suzy dances,
Olga's body is tossed and contorted
until she is deformed beyond recognition.
While the original movie doesn't expose
the undercurrents of witchcraft right away,
2018's wastes no time in doing so,
in overwhelmingly gruesome fashion.
The scariest moment in Midsommar actually
plays out on the western side of the Atlantic,
not with free falls and sledgehammers
in the idyllic Swedish mountains.
Not that the rest of the film doesn't deliver,
but Dani's family's deaths at the hands of her
sister is more disturbing than anything else.
The sound design of the reveal is piercing,
blending perfectly with Dani's screams. The
cinematography and editing are dreamlike, with
first responders moving in slow motion through the
darkness of the family's home. There's something
extra sinister about killing your parents
in their sleep, not to mention the elaborate
lengths to which the troubled girl goes.
Plus, there's the disquieting realization that
when Dani called her parents earlier in the film
to say she thought something was wrong, and the
phone rang next to them as they appeared to sleep,
they were probably already dead.
What do you think of when you think
of "ghosting" someone? If you define
it the way most millennials do, as ending
a relationship with someone by cutting off
all contact without warning or explanation,
then Adrian's behavior in The Invisible Man,
of remaining in someone's life whether they want
you there or not, is pretty much the opposite.
But you could say that Adrian "ghosts"
Cecilia because that is what he literally
becomes. He vanishes from view, yet tortures
her in plain sight while remaining completely
unseen and making her concerns seem crazy.
His actions eventually escalate
beyond psychological abuse and into
taking Cecilia's sister Emily's life in public,
right in front of her, and framing her for it. An
even more chilling element of the public murder
is Adrian's remorseless display of dominance
and manipulation in a completely inhuman act.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite scary movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.